[Music]
here to remind you the mess you made
when you went away you have one of those
in your life
that's a clip i love those lyrics that's
a clip from the hit broadway musical
jagged little pill it was inspired by
alanis morissette's
grammy award-winning album morrissette
is also releasing an audio memoir it's
called
alanis morissette words plus music it's
filled with stories about her life and
music that she recorded in her home
studio
so only on cbs this morning and we'd
like when that happens vladimir dutier
spoke with alanis morissette about this
project
why did you choose this format it's
really the deep dive into the background
behind what the stories are just sort of
following the narratives of a lot of
songs throughout the last
25 years that mean a lot to me and i
don't often talk about it when i'm on
stage performing
did it feel unfamiliar to you as a form
of
art as a form of expression it's
indulgent in the sweetest ways
when i'm on my deathbed at 120 i'll be
looking back and
each record will represent a different
era
the three feelings that i was told i
couldn't feel as a young girl
were angry sad and scared
specifically those three i wasn't
allowed
mauricette's audible project is raw and
honest
just like her music
[Applause]
a life journey a story of self-learning
and
self-discovery
[Music]
it's not a mystery to me that my
unconscious when i write stream of
consciousness lee
that those feelings of anger and deep
sadness
and fear would find their way into my
lyrics
i'm inviting other people to feel those
same feelings at the same time without
shame and without stigma
and it is one of the sweetest exchanges
for me what did you discover
when you started writing about your own
life experiences because there was
something about putting it on paper even
though you've lived it
well the the act of journaling the act
of writing a diary any
kind of process or dialoguing with
different parts of ourselves it's such a
powerful way to not only grow but
to heal and to heal trauma and to find
[Music]
clarity
also in the audible original are new
renditions of some of morissette's
classics
songs she recorded in her home studio
during lockdown
[Music]
like the hit song ironic that first came
out almost 25 years ago
along with years of criticism for
misusing the word
did the criticism hurt you the biggest
irony for me
of this whole thing is that i'm usually
the grammar police
really at first i got a little taste of
my own medicine i didn't even want the
song on the record because it wasn't
wildly personal but i you know everyone
really enjoyed that song
so we put it on there and i loved it i
love that you did
uh a remake of ironic with our pal james
corden
isn't it
oh my gosh so modern james i can't even
regret it for writing those lyrics
call it what you want alongside her new
audible morissette also recorded her
ninth album
titled such pretty forks in the road
[Music]
as she tackles her personal battle with
postpartum depression or
ppd something she told us last year
when you talk about invasive thoughts
like yeah what does that include though
i mean images that are horrifying just a
lot of times about safety about the
people you love your loved ones your
children
how are you doing now i'm not doing too
well
but um it's a hormonal thing it's a
biochemical thing
it is a circumstantial thing
it is uh i mean also
sort of compounded by the pandemic it's
an isolation thing
it's a predisposition to depression it's
rarely ever just depression or just
anxiety there's invasive thoughts the
good news with ppd
is that you that things get better and
for me they get
exponentially better so i have that
light at the end of the tunnel
so appreciate her honesty yep such a
unique voice great to see her really
really good
all right vlad thanks so much